but the two main reasons we need caching
is first of all
lookup from this ssd or even
hard disks is slower compared to ram and
second of all the computation the
computation cost is higher right hey
everyone welcome back and in this video
we'll be discussing about caching which
is one of the most important things to
learn as a back-end developer why you
need caching and how does that exactly
work especially with regards to how
databases work let's go also if you're
new here make sure you leave a like to
the video subscribe to the channel to
receive daily updates on front-end
back-end web development and more on
programming side this video is a part of
code dam's t-shirt giveaway program for
the month if you want to take part and
win an amazing goal damn t-shirt all you
have to do is leave a comment on this
video about what you think and that's it
you are eligible if your comment gets a
heart from code damn you will win a
t-shirt for absolutely free all right so
in this video i'll focus more on the
caching part from the concept from the
angle of databases right because that is
one of the most used area of caching
sure you can cache all sorts of things
and all sorts of computations but
database lookups are very popular now
the reason for that is let's say you
have a database sitting in front of here
right and let's assume this is a sequel
or no seeker i mean it's pretty much the
same thing in terms of caching but you
perform a request you do any select star
or whatever operation now ideally the
reason databases can persist data is
that they do not store your data on ram
right so you have two components the for
storage the first one right here which
we discussed is ram and the second one
is a hard disk right a hard disk or you
know ssd or hdd or whatever you want to
call it this is a permanent storage and
this is a temporary storage which we all
know from class 6 but the thing which we
probably don't know is that databases
have to store their data on hard disks
or ssds or whatever the reason for this
is because rams
are temporary and if the power loses
you're going to lose out that data but
the lookup this lookup
is slow this database this hard disk
lookup is slow so databases use all
sorts of optimizations in order to keep
some data in the memory some data on the
hard disk and so on but the two main
reasons we need caching is first of all
lookup from the ssd or even
hard disks is slower compared to ram and
second of all the computation the
computation cost is higher right and for
the most part i think we focus more on
this thing
this part comes more handy if you have
large data right so if you have large
data with tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of rows or documents if
it's a nosql database then this becomes
more suitable point other than that if
you have complex queries like for
example in mongodb if you're running an
aggregate query that's much complex than
just a simple query for the database
engine therefore the computation part is
the main point there now how does a
redis like or you know any mem cache
radius any caching system solves this
well you see that it's basically nothing
it's redis is a very simple software
which is a wrapper around how you can
store and get and maybe expire things
inside of your ram right if this is your
application right here you're gonna see
that
whenever you call your backend for
example whenever you call the logic
layer
that logic layer first of all checks
that if that result of that query is
existing in cache and when it checks
that if it exists in cache it's actually
just squaring ram in a structured way
right so redis is just your ram which
you can query with the software right so
reader sits in your ram and optimizes
these lookups which you perform but on
the ram storage right you can directly
access the ram and you know just read
and write bits and bytes but it's always
nice to have certain mechanisms and
certain things and certain features
built in for example you can have an
expiry setup would set ex you can set
the key or not depending on if the key
exists or not so these two methods for
example are very useful for radius and
so on and so forth but this video is
more about caching so let's not dive
deep into reddish because we have a full
course on that on coldham if you are
interested you can check out the redis
caching concepts on codedown.com but the
important point here is that redis is
just
ram right in a very simple way the redis
is just ram which allows you to store
these
lookup or these computation results
directly without actually going through
all this database engine and then the
hard disk and so on so an ideal system
should look something like this where
you have a client which accesses the api
somehow whether it's api gateway whether
it's your own managed ec2 instances and
so on if this is a query
the backend sees that there's a query it
performs the query but it first checks
redis or any caching solution if you
already have a cache against that if the
cache is found then you return the query
if it is not found you run it through
the database which you know in most of
the cases if it's i mean if it's a cold
query it goes to the desk and
using
the database engine which is the primary
engine how it queries the file system
gets the data
ideally stores it back into cache for
any future use and be done with it right
so red is in this case acts more as of a
as of a query booster instead of a
critical system because if red is let's
say for some reason is not able to store
this query or you know forgets then you
always will hit the snow branch and
transparently you will get the result
back all the time but this right here
this component speeds up this whole
thing because once the square is hit
then for the next million hits for
example in a single day you might just
hit this route right here which is
probably 2x 3x faster depending on how
complex your query is how complex your
lookup is now we haven't discussed about
what happens here obviously because
right here inside of the database as
well database optimizes certain query
results it sees that hey if you're
accessing this state out way too often
i'm just going to keep that information
in the ram myself right so if you're
accessing certain queries certain
indexes i mean for indexes i believe it
keeps it in the ram for the most part
but even for certain queries the
database engine might do it right but
anyway it's always a good idea to have
a caching system especially if you have
computationally heavy queries or if you
have queries which require a very large
lookup for the databases right 10 000 20
000 quick records and so on so yeah
that's pretty much it for this video if
you enjoyed it make sure you leave a
like and hit the bell icon subscribe to
the channel and let me know in the
comments what do you think about caching
that is all for this one i'm gonna see
you in the next video really soon
[Music]
[Music]
you